comme on est là trois facteurs un
déficit
pluviométrique qui auquel nous devons
nous habituer il est la conséquence d'un
dérèglement climatique et qui s'accentue
deuxièmement un afflux de population
vous avez utilisé des mots qui sont en
de ça de la
réalité à aucun moment les
infrastructures d'eau potable de Mayotte
n'ont été fait en imaginant que la
proportion de personnes en situation
irrégulière serait comparable à celle
que nous connaissons et enfin il faut le
dire une absence de travaux à l'échelle
de ceux qui aujourd'hui ont la
compétence depuis 2017 malgré des moyens
qui sont existants qui n'ont pas été
conduits avec la vitesse et la célérité
qu'il aurait fallu qu'est-ce qu'on fait
la crise la pérennité la crise l'urgence
et la pérenité la crise c'est maintenant
c'est la cellule interministérielle de
crise pilotée par la première ministre
c'est les distributions de bouteilles je
n'insiste pas l'urgence c'est avant
l'été prochain dans des quantités de
travaux que nous lançons déjà et la
pérennité c'est un plan 2024 2027 400
millions d'euros usine des DESS
allemands forage possible retenu cinaire
réutilisation d' usé tous les moyens
tant l'ampleur est importante avec des
taux de fuite qui aile entre 20 et 35 %
sur une partie des réseaux voilà pour
les moyens quelle gouvernance monsieur
le sénateur la compétence elle est
dédiée aux collectivités territoriales
la vérité oblige à dire qu'au cours de
ces dernières années des choses qui
auraient pu fait ne l'ont pas été il n'y
a donc pas de tabou on n'a pas décidé
d'une ration rationalisation mais nous
considérons que pour passer la crise que
nous connaissons sans un appui
exceptionnel de l'État on y arrivera pas
ce sont les sept agents dédiés par mon
ministère c'est les moyens du ministère
de la santé c'est les moyens des outres
mères et qu'au-delà de ce moment-là il
faudra qu'on se demande quel est le bon
niveau de soutien et d'accompagnement de
l'État au collectivité territoriale
merci pour votre
[Applaudissements]
engagement